[Музика]
привіт усім, настав час уроку англійської мови,
мене звати Наталія Шах,
давайте почнемо сьогодні, ми розпочнемо нову тему,
і я хотів би почати з
фотографій, подивіться на зображення, щоб
ми могли побачити  давайте опишемо я бачу, що
різні будівлі пишуть різні
типи будівель це виглядає дуже
сучасно це зображення виглядає як бібліотека,
ймовірно, дуже офіційна будівля, а
ці дві зліва
схожі на дуже стару
будівлю, ймовірно, будівлю десь в Африці
і це  один знову виглядає як дуже
відома будівля в старому стилі, тож що
це за будівля, ви можете здогадатися, що це
не музеї, на жаль, то це
школи, і ми починаємо нову тему, яка
називається шкільне життя або освіта, і
давайте подивимося на зображення
школа кажуть, що у нас є різні
кімнати в школі, у нас є
офіс директора, у нас багато
класних кімнат, у нас є різні поверхи,
наприклад, я бачу шкільний автобус тут, так
що це спільно  ол у дії, давайте подивимося
на ще одну картинку, ця
інша, так що знову це круто в
дії, я бачу шкільний автобус, тож,
ймовірно, діти їдуть до
школи, я бачу маму, яка бере за
руки своїх дітей і приносить  їм до
школи добре, я бачу різних вчителів
тут, на ігровому майданчику
, подивіться, це ігровий майданчик, тому
діти ходять на
урок, вони грають в баскетбол, а
це
, подивіться, я бачу багато книг,
пам'ятайте нашу попередню тему  ми говоримо
про бібліотеки, тож це шкільна
бібліотека, і учні вибирають
для них книги, давайте перейдемо далі, а
це типова класна кімната, право
учні сидять за партами,
я бачу, як один учень піднятий на руку, тож,
ймовірно, він йде  щоб відповісти на
запитання вчителів, давайте подивимося ще на
один приклад, ось це
знову інша кімната. Я можу сказати, що
вчителька пише на дошці,
а учні сидять за партами,
але вони мають свій l  aptops
перед ними, то, ймовірно, це комп’ютерний
клас, він прийшов сюди, оскільки ви бачите, що
студенти також сидять зі своїми
ноутбуками, тому, ймовірно, вони
працюють зі своїми ноутбуками, це може бути
комп’ютерний центр, де студенти виходять в Інтернет
і виконують домашнє завдання  і що це
таке, це місце в коридорі, щоб у
них були готові полиці, у
них була своя книжкова
шафа, щоб вони могли залишити свої речі
там, добре, тож давайте поговоримо про школу
загалом, коли ви почуєте це слово школа,
яке вам спадає на думку  для мене, перш за
все, це вчитель і учні,
це найперші слова, які
спадають мені на думку, а про вас я даю
вам одну хвилину, давайте створимо карту-павука
або карту розуму, тому запишіть слово
школа посередині  і напишіть стільки
слів, скільки зможете зв'язати це зі школою, а
потім ми разом перевіримо добре,
давайте на хвилину
[Музика]
скажи о, це мої слова,
давайте перевіримо разом, щоб у мене були
учні  acher math Уроки гімнастики в класі англійської
мови та історія, тож якщо ми обговоримо
ці слова вчитель та учні,
це люди, які працюють у школі, так математика
історія англійської мови,
що це правильно, це різні
предмети, що щодо уроку
уроки, це те, що ми маємо
на  школа, клас і спортзал
це кімнати в школі, а тепер давайте
потренуємося ще раз, давайте пограємо з ударом,
тому це таймер, я збираюся
запустити бомбу, і поки бомба цокає, я
хотів би, щоб ви згадали стільки слів,
скільки ви  можете зв'язати це з тематичною школою
тут ви можете назвати свої слова, додайте мої
слова, і, ймовірно, ви збираєтеся додати
додаткові слова, тож давайте почнемо, щоб ваша
черга була першою, ви назвіть стільки
слів, скільки зможете пов'язати це з тематичною
школою  щоб ви могли називати свої слова, додайте мої
слова, і, ймовірно, ви
згадаєте щось зайве, що
ви не можете зупинити, поки бомба працює,
продовжуйте ім'я словами готовий давайте
йти до школи уроки англійської мови уроки
цікаво com  e на Я допомагаю тобі, що
ти ще пам'ятаєш,
він може давати прикметники, як-от нудний
фантастичний, все ще працює, слова пам'яті
не зупиняються давай, це останні
секунди, ймовірно, я знаю, що
ти можеш, будь ласка, зроби це давай, а тепер ти
я можу згадати всі слова, які ви можете
назвати імена своїх вчителів,
добре, нарешті, це було складно, добре,
але ви зробили це добре, тепер моя черга,
я сподіваюся, що це не буде
так довго, тому, хлопці, ви перевірте мене, я збираюся  щоб
назвати стільки слів, скільки я можу
пам'ятати зі своєї школи, а ви перевірте мене
готові давайте так учитель учні
уроки класи спортзал кафетерій обідня
перерва історія математика англійська німецька
іспанська мова так мови українська
мова українська література географія
хімія фізика завуч учителі
мають домашнє завдання з їдальні  книги килимок Zack
олівець папір стіл стілець ноутбук проект
онлайн дослідження що ще
mmm події Святкові
дні Різдвяна ялинка
мій улюблений хто мій улюблений вчитель
молодець, що було aga  у складній, але
коли ми починаємо нову тему, це дуже
гарна ідея для мозкового штурму, щоб запам’ятати
якомога більше слів з теми, тож
давайте перейдемо далі, давайте подивимося на таблицю, у нас
є предмети та кімнати в школі, тому
давайте заповнимо цю таблицю  давайте почнемо
з предметів добре то давайте почнемо
з предметів який урок у
нас зараз правильно англійська так давайте
запишемо англійська яка ваша друга
мова французька німецька іспанська давайте
запишемо їх
яка наша рідна мова браво
українська ми також вивчали українську
літературу  у нас також є зарубіжна
література давайте йдемо далі у нас є математика у нас
є природознавство у нас також є хімія та
фізика
що ще буде на уроках це уроки спорту у
нас також є мистецтво у вас є
уроки музики ще щось
географія коли я був дитиною моїм улюбленим
уроком був  історія та анонсовано
допоможіть мені біологія
добре, скажімо, у вас можуть бути додаткові уроки,
ймовірно, вони типові для вашої
школи, ви можете додати їх сюди у свій
список, а тепер давайте рухатися  щодо кімнат,
цей список не буде таким довгим,
тому давайте запишемо кімнати, щоб кімнати,
які кімнати,
насамперед класні кімнати, як цей
клас, добре, у нас також є отвори, у нас
також є спортзал, ви можете мати
басейн, якщо ви  Вам пощастило, що у
вас є ігровий майданчик
Велика Британія Кафетерій у нас може бути кабінет директора, а
як щодо кімнати для вчителів чи
вчительського центру
будь-що інше, коли ми говоримо про
клас, звичайно, у нас може бути величезна
різноманітність класів, це можуть бути кабінети мистецтва,
кабінети хімії чи
науки  класні кімнати це також можуть бути
музичні класи, тому класи для
різних уроків, як-от англійська клас
, а також правильний або комп'ютерний клас такий
різний багато багато різних класів
у школі, тепер давайте йти далі Я
знайшов хмару слів в Інтернеті давайте
подивимося на слова, які є  багато слів
тут, як назад до школи, це тема, тому
ви можете бачити домашнє завдання вчитель вивчає тест
історії студент рюкзак коледж іспит
різні різні слова з th  е тематична
школа, і оскільки тема повернулася до
школи, я чую слово покупки, тож
ви готуєтеся до школи, тому у вас
є багато припасів,
тож давайте знайдемо різні припаси в цій
хмарі, я бачу маркер, тож це
маркер добре  Я бачу, де це
ручка для олівців, що ще
бендер, молодець, скажи, що ти зазвичай у
нас є слово подивись рюкзак, так
що ти кладеш у свій рюкзак
пенал або пенал і що всередині
твого пенала олівець та ручка a
маркер лінійка грабіжник ластик або що ще
о Цезарі, мабуть, добре, у вас також можуть
бути несправні штани для освоєння
добре що ще ви додаєте ви додаєте книги
блокноти zortan добре ви можете додати
свій щоденник hedonic що ще,
ймовірно, ви використовуєте свій планшет на  школа,
щоб ти поклав планшет у рюкзак чи
рюкзак, і він пахне, не забувай
про свій обід або
шмокає, мабуть, яблуком чи пляшкою
води, а тепер давайте перевіримо, що у мене в
рюкзаку, щоб це не камінь, Зак, це
сумка  а я нас  e це для мого ноутбука або
я ходив з цим до школи, так що давайте перевіримо,
що це добре зроблено, це книга, давайте
рухатися далі, це легко, це ідеальний діалог,
хм, що це, це пенал,
то що в мене всередині, давайте
перевіримо, що це  це ручка Брава
так сковорідка ще одна сковорідка як вчитель у
мене величезна різноманітність штанів що це
це не сковорода це пантера Браво добре,
давайте далі, а
що з цього приводу це клейовий стрижень давайте
повторимо клей-стик ідеальний
я сказав вам, що  Ви можете покласти
ножиці, так що це ножиці, давайте
перейдемо до
того, що це за несправні штани Браво для
майстерності і що це, це не
несправна сковорода ми називаємо це маркером добре, давайте
рухатися далі, що це, як ви бачите, я бачу, що
деякі рядки говорять, що це  блокнот
молодець я не люблю носити з собою багато
книг, тому я використовую планшет,
зараз ідеальний планшет, подивіться, у мене тут є міні-коробка,
а тут багато міні-запасів,
давайте обговоримо, що тут, скажімо
, подивіться, у мене є  міні степлер це дуже
зручно, тому що якщо ви цього не зробите  мати достатньо
місця в сумці, можна використовувати так багато
речей, скажімо, це тип салату, міні-
салат, навіть виглядати, навіть міні-салат,
коли я подорожую, це зручний набір для мене. У
мене також є точилка, щоб заточити
олівець, а також у мене є папір  кліпси добре,
і в мене є синя бірка синя, я використовую, щоб
додати кілька фотографій на стіну, і це
не залишає жодних уколів, тому користуватися ним дуже
легко, це мій міні-комплект, добре, тепер
давайте упакуємо всі речі назад, так що міні-
комплект що таке  це
допоможіть мені я поклав ці речі в сумку,
і ви називаєте це
добре зроблено планшет блокнот додайте
книгу книжку насмешник клей стик несправні штани
пенал це був олівець Браво ручки
ідеальні я додаю їх до сумки і що
це за Cesar's  дивовижно, тому я готовий до
школи добре, давайте рухатися далі, давайте створимо
наші власні хмари слів з нашими словами,
давайте персоналізуємо їх, і для цього я буду
використовувати свій ноутбук, тож давайте зробимо це разом, щоб
ви виходили в Інтернет, тепер ви можете бачити на своєму
екрані моє  екран, тож ми разом виходимо в
Інтернет, щоб ви входили на веб-сайт  world
art.com, і ми збираємося створити наше
власне хмара слів, тому, як ви бачите тут, у нас
є різні форми хмар слів,
і ми бачимо кнопку «створити», що каже, що
ми натискаємо кнопку, і ми додаємо слова,
які ми хочемо використовувати просто  слідкуй за мною, я
збираюся додати студентів-вчителів,
зараз давайте виберемо форму, коли ви будете
готові, натисніть кнопку візуалізації, щоб
ви могли побачити свою хмару слів, якщо вона вам не
подобається, ви можете змінити її змінити
шрифт змінити форму  вигляд Я
думаю, що це красиво. Я збираюся використовувати
це зараз, ви натискаєте кнопку завантажити
і ви зберігаєте його на своєму комп'ютері як
зображення, і це Фредді, тому це
буде домашнє завдання, я хотів би, щоб ви
створили своє власне слово
хмари подивіться створіть власну хмару слів
із тематичної школи, і ви можете надіслати
її мені на перевірку, тому дозвольте мені нагадати
вам мою електронну адресу
Natalia dot school онлайн на gmail.com,
і я готова перевірити ваші хмари слів
там Ізабель  і нам потрібно зупинити
урок, дуже дякую і  побачимося
наступного разу, до побачення
[Музика].